На годиннику майже десята. Однак 50-річний Андрій Бондарчук,
чиновник з десятилітнім стажем та ексмер нині окупованого Дебальцевого
на роботу не поспішає.
Його кабінет - його ж автомобіль.
Починати робочий день може будь-коли.
Андрій працює таксистом в одній із служб таксі.
Мені так хибно здавалося, що
це пониження у деяких моментах.
Але тепер я не комплексую.
Шість років тому Андрію довелося думати не про престиж професії, а  про те, як прогодувати родину.
Тоді він на цьому ж автомобілі переїхав з дружиною і трьома дітьми з Донецька до Києва.
Подалі від війни.
Я відчував небезпеку.
Тому що повне безвладдя і ці люди - окупанти,
які чинили повне беззаконня, відбирали машини,
людей вбивали, люди зникали, арештовували, катували.…
Багато людей тоді приїхали з території країни агресора, і місцеві їх узагалі не знали.
Їх можна було вирахувати за акцентом і за "поребриком".
А ще вони шукали "скобяной" магазин. Ви знаєте що це таке?
І донеччани не знають. Це означає магазини, де продаються металеві вироби.
Тобто скоби - це ковані ланцюги, замки, ключі...
Ось це "скобяний" магазин. В Україні так не кажуть, тож легко "спалитися"...
З трьома вищими освітами за спеціальностями історія, право та державна служба
він міг би легко знайти іншу роботу.
Стати чиновником чи викладачем Андрію не раз пропонували.
Втім, каже, робота в службі таксі оплачується значно краще.
А гроші родині переселенців вкрай потрібні. Зокрема - щоб сплатити кредит за житло.
У мене була кар'єра. Політична кар'єра в демократичних країнах переривається.
Бо у нас, на відміну від Росії і Білорусії є демократичні вибори.
Я був депутатом міської, обласної ради, був міським головою.
У мене три перемоги особисті, а потім програв вибори і я пішов в іншу сферу діяльності.
За кермом таксі Андрій несподівано відкрив для себе нове покликання.
Розповідає пасажирам про війну, про все те, що на власні очі бачив на Сході Україні.
Не всі поділяють погляди таксиста. За це йому часом навіть знижують рейтинги.
Я переживу цей рейтинг. У мене він відмінний. Але для мене важливіше донести це.
Навіть росіянам, як би їм не було неприємно.
Ті, які підтримують політику свого президента, я вважаю, що вони несуть відповідальність за цю війну,
бо є частиною цієї країни.
І на виборах підтримують політику цієї людини або не підтримують.
Тому їм це може бути неприємно. Але не всім.
Деякі розуміють, а деякі навіть вибачаються, декому соромно за політику своїх керманичів…
За майже чотири роки таксування Андрій Бондарчук перевіз понад 50 тисяч пасажирів.
Це вдвічі більше, аніж населення того ж Дебальцевого.
Серед пасажирів і політики, і зірки кіно, й співаки. Чимало іноземців.
Якщо взяти іноземців, то я перевозив представників чи не всіх посольств.
Це й американське, німецьке, французьке. Пам'ятаєте, Александр Гуґ
Формально його посада заступник спостережної комісії ОБСЄ. Але я його теж возив.
Мене дуже дивує, чому в цій місії 43 росіян і чому там немає українців.…
Але я знаю чому, бо формально в нас з Росією не війна…
Андрій може розповісти щось цікаве майже про кожну, навіть найменшу вулицю Києва.
Та його улюблене місце в столиці - тиха Русанівка. А ще - качалка в Гідропарку.
І навіть під час тренувань розмірковує про політику.
Білоруси молодці. Не здаються. Борються за свободу і демократію.
В центрі Європи нарожується дуже красива білоруська нація.
Напередодні місцевих виборів чиновницький досвід Андрія Бондарчука доволі затребуваний.
Як тренер готує нині кандидатів та штаби різних політичних партій.
Каже, політичні амбіції не згасли і, можливо, на наступні місцеві вибори ще позмагається за депутатство.
А поки рейтинги для таксиста-ексмера створюють вдячні пасажири.
В його робочому профілі сотні схвальних відгуків.
За найкращі 45 хвили в таксі, які в мене були…. Мені дуже приємно, дуже приємно…